o homem Ele tem essa tolice com um
negócio de mulher você pode prestar
atenção às vezes a mulher ela quer falar
de um problema com um homem e o homem
Ele só conversa de problema com outro
homem se ele quiser resolver o problema
Acho meu carro tá pagando toda vez
apagando né mas todo dia eu vou ligar
duas voltinhas para você rapaz você sabe
por quê problema é ignição é mesmo levar
para os cabos dar uma olhada pronto e a
mulher não quando ela faz de um problema
com um homem é porque ela quer dialogar
conversar olha veja só ela quer
conversar com o Conjugue dela né o
companheiro mas o homem não entende ele
só quer resolver o problema Por isso que
às vezes o homem só ignorante amor a
Ketlin tá toda estranha comigo eu não eu
falo com ela ela não me responde direito
não me dá atenção sabe a gente é tão
chegada e do nada passa porque aqui
ainda conversa com essa desgraça mano
dessa é para jogar o que tu fica com
negócio de um negócio de
conversar com não sei o quê que não
gosta de tu ave maria dá para falar
contigo não John meu Deus ai